everyone grows up I never forget about
anything everyone behind it everyone
moves on
but some friendships Christopher Robin
who last a lifetime
are you glad to see me follow mr.
everyone welcome to London
thank you for the ride the director of
fighting another life that was a shell
for that explains why it's no good for
climbing is this Christopher rocks rated
PG in theaters August 3rd Oh
what should happen if you forget about
me
Simeon fair oh never forget about you
pay promise Havel and I'm a hundred we
should be working this weekend Robin but
I promised my wife and daughter I'd take
them away this weekend all hands on deck
you won't be coming to the cottage well
it can't be helped your life is
happening now right in front of you
what to do what to do what to do what to
do indeed poor Christopher Robin hello
the tree I remember was in the
countryside not here in London thus our
opening
I suppose it's where it needs to be
let's a silly explanation watch thank
you who why are you here oh yes I need
your help
I've lost all of my friends let's get to
the bottom of this look up here I come
it would appear that I am stuck
have you just eaten honey I have not
just eaten I wonder which way I always
get to where I'm going by walking away
from where I have been don't you that's
the way I do it turn
hello you're Christopher Robin it's you
damn let's gonna see if identified
piglets I've already stayed far too long
[Music]
so nice to see you all again much thank
you sir little bear
wrong about work I was wrong about
everything and I've got to get back to
my family for a while
Christopher Robin I would have liked it
to go on for a while longer
perhaps it's our turn to save
Christopher
[Music]
you must be Madeleine wait you're the
bear of my father's floorings yes do you
know where he is I did I just saw the
host Rick bus tourism
[Music]
picket if anyone wants to clap now is
the time to do it I don't remember being
cherry
people say nothing is impossible but I
do nothing every day
no poo that's not never mind
you
you